hello ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the Tim Ferriss show what you're about
to hear is part two of a multi-part
conversation with Kevin Kelly co-founder
of Wired magazine and all-around
fascinating guy if you didn't catch the
first part you might want to do that
before venturing in but we cover a lot
of topics and it's a conversation so if
you don't mind your stories is more of a
jigsaw puzzle then by all means keep on
listening so without further ado please
enjoy part two of the Tim Ferriss show
with Kevin Kelly all shownotes links etc
can be found at 4-hour workweek comm
forward slash podcast and thank you for
listening at this altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking can I ask
you a personal question
I must - medic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton does religion
play a large part in your life right now
in a certain sense not in a kind of
ritualistic sense I just wrote a book
called what technology wants excellent
book I highly recommend it it was it was
a theory of technology and I was trying
to put technology in the context of the
cosmos so I think what religion gives me
is permission to think about cosmic
questions I'm right in the middle of
finishing a Kickstarter funded graphic
novel that's about angels and robots and
the intention there was to fictionalize
the idea that robots would some days
have souls but these Souls would be
coming from angels and so that there was
this intersection of these two kind of
possible worlds of conscious robots who
were in sold by angels and and and the
reason why this was sort of interesting
was that the idea was that the angels
that install us have been trained
they've been given moral guidance but if
you don't give the spirit some kind of
moral guidance than they can wreak havoc
and so was this idea that when we make
robots we're also going to have to train
them to be ethical mm-hmm we just can't
make a free being and not train it so it
was a way to rehearse and think about
some of the consequences of technology
today so I think my religion gives me
permission to ask those questions
without embarrassment to say well what
is the general direction of the arc of
evolution what is it pointed somewhere
how does technology fit into the greater
cosmos what does it mean what drives it
why is there more of it is this a good
thing and so I think having a kind of I
consider this kind of an other view so I
have a other view that I'm sympathetic
to
other worldviews I don't necessarily
have to believe all the other worldview
but I get the idea that if you have an
another worldview that can be very
helpful in seeing other worldviews
mm-hmm so people have a worldview even
though they don't know it but I have a
worldview and I know that I ever really
everybody has a religious or a spiritual
orientation even if they're atheists
they still have one and so there are
some assumptions that are at the basis
of it and I like to question assumptions
including my own assumptions mm-hmm
two things I can't resist asking and we
can spend as much or as little time and
this is he'd like but recently grappling
with a lot of these issues that I've
been grappling with some of which are
existential some of which are related to
death limited time on the planet I've
become deeply fascinated by indigenous
use of plant medicine and I've had some
very transformative experiences that are
difficult to put into words because they
make you sound like a complete crazy
person yeah yeah there's a somethingness
that is very difficult to communicate
without sounding like you should be
institutionalized what do you think the
role for people who aspire to do the
greatest good in the world what is the
role of that type of direct experience
and is it possible to benefit from that
type of for lack of a better descriptor
spiritual experience without a religious
framework around it yeah yeah no it's a
really good question so my little
personal story there of course this I
was basically I was basically a hippie I
worked for the hippie catalog in the
hearth catalog which was not hippies
living in San Francisco and all my
friends were drug-taking hippies but I
for some reason never did I just had no
appetite or inclination at all forever
taking any drugs or smoking pot or
anything and when I was 50 years old I
decided that I would like to take LSD
sacramentally on my 50th birthday and I
did and I arranged with
had a guide and I had a purpose setting
and I had some acid that came from a
source that was extremely reliable and
it was a sacrament and it was a very
profound sacrament and I think yeah you
can use drugs and recreationally and for
entertainment and I think that can go
somewhere but I think there's another
powerful use of it which is kind of what
you're talking about it would nice to
elevate one outside of yourself to lose
yourself to be in contact with other
things beyond your ego and I think it
can be done and I think unfortunately
because of the illegal status that we've
had for a long time the rituals and the
practice around that have not had a
chance to be developed or communicated
actually trying to find this information
was extremely hard there's one book that
I did find eventually from a guy who was
doing LSD experiments while they were
still legal and was able to accumulate
enough wisdom about it that that would
be the one place I would point people to
but I think it is important that the
context and expectations and the the
setting they call it that revolves
around it is very important and I do
believe that these can be extremely
profound and powerful experiences for
good they can remain long after and you
know most people who understand this and
don't abuse it understand that in fact
the experience was not in the pill was
not in the chemical it was a real
experience and so unfortunately there's
so much other stuff circulating around
the use of these drugs and the misuse of
them that that kind of information is
often very very difficult to find but I
do think maybe we're seeing a moment now
in the US where the second prohibition
is being undone and at least pot will
become legal and maybe we can return to
revitalizing you know the traditions and
the necessary settings are around that
and expectation that not just pot or LSD
but even other synthetic drugs can be
stream
they powerful in removing the ordinary
guards that we have them we have an ego
for on purpose we have all these things
to keep us you know sane in a day-to-day
functional standpoint yeah right and so
if you remove it completely
you can become dysfunctional but if you
remove it deliberately and with great
care
you can be opened up and I think it's
that you know I think there's an
expertise there I think there's a lot of
other things that then if we have the
freedom and the wisdom to not abuse it I
think it can be extremely powerful do
you recall the title of the book okay so
this is or how people might search for
it yes so this is a one of the many
resources that I recommend in my book
cool tools and cool tools is a big
catalogue of possibilities it has about
1500 different items a lot of them are
kind of like hand tools you know pliers
and the great cordless drill but it's
much more than that and I include things
like what if you wanted to have a
psychedelic experience it was
transformative what do you do and I
would recommend this book or I mean
there's lots of other things in it but
the I don't actually have the book in
front of me I should I think it's called
I don't remember
it's okay I will show notes we will list
it as the right one and there's also a
little tiny book that came from England
there was a cartoon guide that gave kind
of a street a nun judgmental view of all
the different drugs there were and what
each one kind of didn't dent in what the
plus and minuses are without you know
recommending or forbidding them it's
just saying this this is what it is that
information also believe it or not is
really in short supply it's like you
know what do you do with this and how
does it work and tell me the facts I
don't need to you're a lecture either
way like whether this is greater this is
terrible but just tell me what's going
on right as you know I mean that kind of
information sometimes is extremely in
short supply it's very difficult to find
information that isn't politicized yeah
inaccurate or like you said so shrouded
in either fear or
irrational optimism that it's almost
intelligible and certainly generally
useless we'll put those books and the
show notes for people I want to come
back to one thing you said far far
earlier and that was related to the
pieces that you tried to give away that
eventually wouldn't die and came back
were there any common threads any
patterns in those pieces that that you
can pick out as being sort of a uniquely
Kevin Kelly theme if for life yeah one
of the things that I discovered in my
six months of trying to live as if I was
going to die in six months because as I
was coming closer to that date which
happened to be Halloween October 31st it
was I kept cutting off my future I mean
I may be like you I kind of tend to live
in the future much more than past I'm
always imagining I'm saving this for
something when I'm gonna do this I'm
looking forward I'm gonna do this here
and so I was very much in the future and
then something that future was being cut
down day by day and I was like and I was
thinking like why am I taking pictures
I'm taking photographs because I'm not
gonna be here in another two months or
something so so there was all these
things that I'm kind of cutting out and
as I was cutting them out I had this
realization which was the thing I took
away from this thing which was that I
was becoming less human mmm that to be
fully human we have to have a future we
have to look forward to the future that
is part of us is looking into the future
and so after I came out of the and I
kind of embraced that I'm saying well
you know that future forward facing
that's what I do that's what that's what
I want to do that's what I write about
and in thinking about the future one of
the things that it's very hard because
the paradox about the future is that
there are lots of impossible things that
happen all the time and if someone from
the 100 years ago I would come back and
tell us things there's a lot of stuff
we're just not gonna believe is like
that's just that's crazy just like if we
went back a hundred years and told them
what was going on now they would say you
know that's just not gonna happen I mean
we could even go back 20 years I can go
back 20 years and say we're gonna have
like Google's true
views of all the cities of the world and
we're gonna have you know encyclopedias
for free that's edited by anybody you
know they would say you know there's no
way and that's all I know tell them you
know most of us for free and they were
saying there is no economic model in the
world now for that and there isn't
mm-hmm but here it is so the dilemma is
is that any true forecast about the
future is going to be dismissed mm-hmm
any future that is believable now is
going to be wrong like if people believe
it is wrong if they don't believe it you
know where does it get you dismissed so
there is a very fine line saying
something that is right on the edge of
plausibility at the same time right on
the edge of having a chance of being
true and what I discovered that was
helpful in trying to get away from the
kind of assumptions that - it just kind
of extrapolate hmm was to think
laterally was to go sideways one thing
just take whatever was that everybody
knew and say well what if that wasn't
true what would be a good example of
that or an example like everyone says
okay Moore's law will continue mm-hmm
well whatever Moore's law didn't
continue what would that mean what would
happen and you can maybe that I could
say for the audience but I'll just say
even to remind me Moore's law is what is
it every 18 months the the size and cost
of Technology will decrease by 50%
something along those lines
let's say even more no there's speed
involved as well right more or less say
that but but let's say something right
now we live in a world where every year
the technology is better and cheaper
what if that wasn't true right got it
what if every year starting like you
know couple years now stuff was better
bit more expensive that's that's a
completely different world right
everyone assumes right now things are
gonna get better and cheaper mm-hmm well
what if that wasn't true mm-hmm so you
can take kind of assumption again that's
something that no one's really examining
like well when things are right about is
the fact that we're going to have a
population implosion globally that the
global population will
drastically reduce in 100 years mail
will have less population far far less
than we have right now and so all right
I have to bind at that what because I've
thought a lot about this and the what
they call the mallow Malthusian dilemmas
is that going to be do you think
pandemic related nuclear weapon related
all of the above none of those none of
those no AI coming in the the the rise
of the machines no okay it's just pure
demographics so if you look at the
current trends in fertility rates in all
the developed countries everywhere
except for the u.s. they're already
either below replacement level mmm-hmm
so replacement level means that you're
just sustaining the populations Latian
just replaces itself if it's below it
means that there's getting there's
getting less and less so Japan all these
Europe they're all below replacement the
u.s. is an exception because of only
because of immigration mmm-hmm more
people coming in otherwise we would be
there and this would not be any news to
anybody but the real news would point to
a developing world but you know Mexico
is now aging faster than the US China is
aging faster because of their one-child
policy of course Japan is is completely
there way underwater completely so even
the one exception is sub-saharan Africa
and there's really kind of debate right
now about how fast or whether they're
slowing down but generally the round the
world South America the rest of Asia the
rate and fertility continues to drop and
here's the thing is that the demographic
transition that is happening everywhere
where people become urban so every
forecast shows the urbanity the
certification of the population
continuing and I can't think of any
counter force to stop this huge
migration at the scale that we're seeing
into the city and as that happens the
birth rates drop down and even in places
like Singapore or other places where
they have taken very very active
countermeasures of
for having kids and Wow daycare forever
bonuses none of these work in terms of
actually trying to raise fertility
levels so you have to understand that to
go above replacement level the average
woman has to have 2.1 kids
well that means there has to be tons and
tons of women who have three or four
kids right make up for those how many
people do you know with that many kids
you know living in cities and they're
just very easy not yeah there's not
enough of them so and this is a
projection some of these are UN
productions they have three three they
have a low high and and medium and a low
one is not good news because there's not
a large cultural counterforce
for women to have three a lot you know
very high percentage of the population
to have three or four kids in a modern
world and that's why the the population
continues to decrease every year
what type of this is perhaps a tangent
but one of the big debates in my head
right now is to marry or not to marry to
have kids and not deaf kids I never
thought those would even be questions in
my mind and yet here I am in and now
they are what are your thoughts on
having children what type of people this
is very broad but should have children
or shouldn't have children whichever way
of answering is easier or how to even
think about that question I think people
who are privileged at which you are
should have children because you can
bestow so many privileges and
opportunities to your children and if
the world is to be populated why not
populate it with the children who have
as many opportunities as possible I also
say from my own experience of growing up
one of many kids and having well I have
three kids one of my other regrets in
life is not having a fourth but we were
just started a little bit too late and
we were unable to have a fourth but all
my kids wished we had a fourth too and I
would say that as a gift to your kids to
have more than one hmm and I know that
from hanging out in China where so many
kids grew up only children and this
really really missed that there is a
total gift
there's siblings the brothers to each
other that is really very profound and
there is also I know from my friends who
have had lots of kids that there is a
current amount of teaching from the the
older to the younger and that's a lot of
what they learn and that the curve of
the amount of energy that you have to
expend actually after three doesn't
really matter right erm to the parents
got it I have one friend who has nine
kids they have another friend of his
seven Wow
and basically how do they do that well
the older kids were helping to parent
the younger kids it's the only way that
it really works but that is actually
basically they have you know they have
five parents instead of having two
parents right it's very traditional in a
way I mean traditional meaning reaching
back thousands or tens of thousands of
years it is of course in the old days
men had twelve born but they barely hit
twelve kids survived right so that
actually is a very recent I mean sort of
like it's like the 1800s kind of on I
hang out with the Amish a lot and they
still have these very large families and
they all survive so they have kind of in
some sense it's sort of an unnatural
expansion then one of my predictions
again going back to kind of like the
assumptions one of my predictions is
that you know in America in a hundred
years from now whatever it is it'll be
the complete countryside is run by the
Amish the Amish take over the entire
side because they never sell and they
have like eight kids and they're always
people living in the cities and like
everybody's happy you know you really
drive out to the Amish lands this is
fantastic and they're very happy you
know doing their thing and running the
farms and so I've been predicting for
years that how much we come and start
buying upstate New York and that's
exactly what they're doing right now why
do you spend so much time with the Amish
this is news to me but very very
interesting and how long has that been
going on for a while and does your beard
have anything is there any relation to
the image I had the beard before my
interest in the Amish I can show you
some pictures when I was 19 years old I
do have so those who don't know I have
an Amish beard which means I have a
beard without a mustache the reason why
the Amish don't have mustaches is it was
at the time that they were kind of
adopting her dress code the mustache was
all
military men had mustaches so they were
anti military they refused to serve in
armies they don't even vote but so is
there kind of rejection of the military
by shaving off their mustache I hang out
with the Amish because their adoption of
technologies is like seem to us totally
crazy
because first of all they're not
Luddites they're complete hackers they
love hacking technology they have
something called hamish electricity
which is basically pneumatics a lot of
these farms have a big diesel they don't
have electricity but they have a big
diesel generator in the barn that pumps
up this compressor that sense
high-pressure air tubes down tubing into
their barn into the homes and so they
have converted like they're sewing
machine washing machine is stuff to
pneumatic okay seems like a bit of a
sidestep of the word of god so we'll
have like you'll have horse-drawn
buggies and horse drones farm implements
and the horses will be pulling this
diesel generated combine and you're what
are they doing okay right but but in
fact if you look at our own lives and
I've done this many times I can ask you
Tim or you can ask me there'll be some
weird thing like we don't have TV in our
house but I've got internet it's like
what is that about right right so we all
have these things but here's the
difference is the Amish do it
collectively mmm they're very selective
they're selecting their technology
collectively as a group and secondly
they have to articulate because they
doing collectively have to articulate
what the criteria is a lot of us are
adopting you try this we try that we
don't have any kind of like logic or
reason or theory or framework for why
we're doing stuff it's just one parade
of stuff but the Amish have a very
particular criteria and their criteria
is there two things that they're looking
for the main thing they want to do the
main reason why we have all these
restrictions like course and buggy and
all the stuff is that they want to have
these communities very strong
communities so they noticed that if you
have a car that you'll drive out and
shop somewhere out of the community or
you go to church somewhere out of the
community or
whatever it is but if you have a horse
and buggy you can go only 15 miles and
so everything has to happen your entire
life hat you have to support the
community you have a community within 15
miles you have to visit the sick and you
have to shop locally so you're shopping
with your neighbors so when a new
technology comes along they say will
this strengthen our local community or
send us out and then the second thing
that they're looking at is with families
so the goal of the typical Amish man or
women is to have every single meal with
their children for every meal their
lives until they leave home they have
breakfast and they have lunch and they
have dinner so breakfast and lunch is
that they go to one-room schoolhouse and
they they pedal back for lunch that
their parents have with them and that
means that the businesses ideally in
their backyard so they have they have a
lot of like shops and stuff if they're
not a farmer and they have a backyard
shop which is actually has to be kind of
clean ish because it is in their
backyard right it's like not my well it
is in their backyard so they really are
you know they really want to be sure
that their dental working shops and
stuff would say I really try to keep
non-toxic and work because it's in their
backyard and so that means that they can
come home for lunch they have breakfast
lunches so they're there on the premises
and they have every single meal with
their children until they leave and so
they say it was a little will this
technology allow us to do that will help
us do that or will it work against that
and then like right now they're they've
been deciding whether to accept
cellphones or not even though they don't
have landline phones
so they're basically they're going to
accept cell phones and they do that by
there's always some Amish early adopter
who's trying things and they say okay
Ivan Bishop says you can can st. get
permissions is you can try this but
we're watching you
we're gonna see what effect this has on
your family on your community you have
to be ready to give it up anytime we say
that it's not working and they do this
in a kind of Paris by Paris so it's very
decentralized and so they try out always
trying out new technologies and they're
always looking to see this is this
strengthening the families is just
strengthening the communities if not we
don't want it and what if you have two
questions I guess the first is since
you're normally as I understand it
based on the west coast and northern
california how do you get out to the
Amish or is there a separate community
closer by and then secondly what if you
incorporated into your own life or your
your own family that originated from the
Amish yeah so I don't get to see them as
often as I want but actually when I go
east I have some contacts that I will
exercise and I've tried to get like to
stay overnight and go to church and a
buggy or something
this is Pennsylvania well actually
Pennsylvania is the heart of it but
actually there are more communities in
Ohio where my brother lives no kidding
Iowa there's a lot more happening in New
York so so the the Pennsylvania are the
kind of ground zero and zero but in fact
there are bigger more extensive
communities outside of Pennsylvania
realize that yeah the Amish diaspora it
literally are just buying up farmland
there they're expanding they're
constantly expanding they have a very
small attrition rate very large families
they all are buying basically they're
buying farms and stuff for their for
their children
and they never sell and so they also
don't move into areas as a they have a
minimum number of families that may need
to move in at once mm-hmm
but what did I learn from them well one
of the things that we had particularly
when we had younger kids was kind of
technological sabbaticals mm-hmm or
Sabbath's I should say mm-hmm and I've
now seen other families who aren't even
you know aren't even religious adopt
that same thing which is once a week you
take a break from either you can define
it however you want it to screen or the
keyboard or or connectivity or something
and you step back and you do that not
because it's like terrible or poison but
because it's so good you know there's
lots of people were kind of like they're
gonna drop out from Twitter they're kind
of like oh this is like the toxin I can
detox or something I think that's
entirely the wrong way to think about it
is you want to take breaks on this not
because they're toxic but because
they're so good it's like you want to
step back so that you can re-enter it
and with a renewed perspective with a
renewed appreciation
with having spent time looking in a
different way and I think that kind of
rhythm of having saboteurs and then
release about vacations wherever
retreats and then every 7 years or
whatever as you take a true sabbatical I
think that kind of rhythmic
disconnection or Sabbath I think is very
powerful something that worked very well
and was something that we had in our
family
I take Saturday's off as it turns out as
my screen last day I really I really try
to make that a weekly occurrence and
it's incredible the effect that that it
has the sort of galvanizing effect of
just a mere 24 hours not even that if
you just consider the waking hours every
seven years a vacation or a sabbatical
of how long in your case or your
family's case yeah partly because my
wife actually is granted a sabbatical
from the company she works or which is
genetic it's one of two companies
actually have a official sabbatical for
all their researchers at least and it's
very meager it's six weeks mm-hmm of
course you know a six week sabbatical is
basically a European annual vacation
it's three years so yes
so we're do something do something
different so this year we're taking one
and we're going to camp in national
parks for one month of it and then the
other two weeks we'll go to Asia but we
haven't been to a lot of the national
parks I'm gonna do a different kind of
project that I haven't done before and
we'll do some kind of car camping we
haven't really done a big road trip like
that so it's all new for us what is the
longest in the last few years that
you've gone without checking email Oh
probably two weeks ahead in China and
how do you manage that
all right well BZ was like I just I was
unable to pick it up because China was
blocking Google it makes it more
challenging and I was I was in some
remote places and so even the connection
was hard but it was like they weren't
play they won't letting me get it I'm
not a mobile person my first smartphone
was an iPhone 5 and I still not using it
properly I use it for phone calls yeah I
don't I don't use my iPhone as an input
device either I just yeah drives me nuts
but I can't type when I travel I like to
leave everything I spent a lot of my
time sitting in front of a computer I'm
kind of like the Zen you know walk walk
sit sit don't wobble so like I'm here
I'm like really online and then when I
leave this studio I don't want to be
connected at all and I won't be and I'm
not checking email I'm not checking this
other stuff and I can go days typically
I'll go days without checking even in
the u.s. if I'm traveling and then if
I'm overseas
I will go probably three or four days
before I get the email that's pretty
typical do you uh let me shift gears
just a little bit I'm looking at huh
looking at long now.org I recommend
everybody take a look at it the long now
foundation and humans are generally I
would say pretty bad at thinking long
term certainly when it comes to habit
change very very high failure rate with
long-term incentives you're gonna get
diabetes in 20 years for instance as
opposed to you'll have more sex if you
have a six-pack
when it comes to diet but the long now
foundation I just want to read a few
things on this website for people so the
long enough foundation was established
in 1996 written as zero one nine nine
six to creatively foster long-term
thinking and responsibility in the
framework of the next 10,000 years then
you have the ten thousand year clock
which is a monument scale multi
millennial all mechanical clock is an
icon to long-term thinking the Rosetta
project building an archive of all
documented human languages long bets
featured bed is here Warren Buffett
protege Partners LLC a public arena for
enjoyable competitive predictions of
interest to society with philanthropic
money at stake and then revive and
restore which is bringing extinct
species back to life so there is a lot
here
can you explain to people because I've
greatly enjoyed many of the seminars and
speeches of long now foundation I'm a
supporter if I suppose I've even spoken
there on stage and love the
email synopses that Stewart sends out
what is the function of the long now
foundation when what is the value the
long enough addition is kind of reactive
is reacting to the very inherent
short-term bias that our society
particularly this technological society
particularly say the Silicon Valley
exhibits which is often a focus on the
next quarter or the next two quarters
the next year results needing to be
immediate
you know instant satisfaction if
something is not on Netflix streaming we
don't even wait for the DVD it's this
fairly kind of very fast-paced
short-term thinking and also somewhat
blinded by the fact that we don't have a
lot of a sense of history either that
we're kind of ignorant about what's
happened in the past and so the term the
long now came from Brian Eno who noticed
that we have a very short now which is
like the next five minutes the last five
minutes so the long now is a wait is an
attempt to kind of expand that so that
we as a society and as individuals would
try to think about things at a
generational or civilizational scale so
like how about like working on something
that might take longer than your own
lifetime to accomplish so you start
something now they maybe make it so that
it might take like the cathedrals of old
and what if we were trying to make
something that you know might need 25
years to accomplish how can we do that
so we're trying to encourage people to
think in that perspective to take that
in perspective and then to maybe move in
that direction we're not necessarily
saying we have to have like the
azimoff's foundation where we have to
have like a master plan for the next
hundred years and we're going to plan
out the future no we're agnostic about
what it is that people make or do we're
just saying that it would benefit having
thinking about the long term and I've
often heard some people who advised to
counseling to individuals about kind of
thinking about the long term in your own
life even though you might want to
act kind of locally and be spontaneous
but you do want you do want to kind of
keep in mind the fact that you know
you'll be around for a while
whether it's putting some savings away
or working on a skill that may take some
time more than the six months or a year
to acquire or you know whatever it is
that you can have both perspectives and
so we're not attempting to get rid of
the need for people to survive I mean
for companies to have a profit this year
we're saying there can be additional
perspectives in addition to that where
we say we commit to like a cyanide
program of science research where it's
pure science and the results of the say
in mathematics is one of the most
profound things that we can invest in
even though most of the things in the
beginning seemed to be non utilitarian
they don't have any purpose but we know
from our own history that you know in 20
years they'll pay off in some way or
other and so being able to kind of
construct a society so that we can allow
the rewards of long-term investment
long-term thinking long term perspective
that would make us a better civilization
I love the long enough foundation
I encourage everybody to check it out
long now.org
if you want more of the tim ferriss show
you can subscribe to the podcast on
itunes or goto for our blog comm f where
you'll find an award-winning blog tons
of audio and video interview stories
with people like Warren Buffett and Mike
Shinoda from Lincoln Park the books plus
much much more follow tim on twitter at
twitter.com/dspacestv or on facebook at
facebook.com slash Tim Ferriss until
next time thanks for listening
you